[LIGHT TECHNO MUSIC]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And here we
are in the Code Labs area.
This is a special part
of Google I/O where
if you've always wanted to learn
a new API, or tool, or service,
you get to come here and
work on the Code Lab.
And if you have any issues or
you want to get in more depth,
you can ask a Googler
for their help.
Any question you happen to have.
I'd like to learn
a little bit more
about what it feels like
to do Code Lab here at I/O,
and to do that, Claire.
CLAIRE: Hey, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How you doing?
CLAIRE: I'm great.
It's been a long couple of
days but a fun couple of days.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I hope
that means a lot of people
learning a lot of things.
CLAIRE: Oh, most definitely.
We've had lines waiting
pretty much the entire day.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's very cool.
So what's the setup like here?
CLAIRE: The set
up here is a bunch
of computers that are all
preconfigured with the steps
to do--
learn pretty much
whatever you want.
You can tell what's going on
by the status of these lights
up here.
If they're green, it
means the computer
is ready to go, ready for
you to come up and learn.
If they're blue it means
Code Labs in progress.
And when they turn red,
it means that someone
needs a little bit of help,
or has got a question,
and one of our staff
will zip over right away
and help them out with that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's totally cool.
Now this is a special Code
Lab station that actually
has a whole bunch of devices.
What's going on there?
CLAIRE: That's right.
So right now we're in our
special IoT Code Labs section.
We've got a couple
different devices over here
that people can run a bunch of
various of our Code Labs on.
And they'll actually get to
interact and play with them.
This one's got some buttons,
and lights, and numbers.
It's got a button that's very
fun-- very fun to play with.
It's a good time
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, is there anything
else you want to
say about the day?
How's it been going?
CLAIRE: Really good.
We've had a lot of people with
very insightful questions,
a lot of people showing
a lot of enthusiasm
for the subjects, which is
always my favorite thing
to see.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome,
thank you so much.
CLAIRE: Thanks, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's the Code Labs area.
Thanks so much for joining me.
Remember, I'm Timothy Jordan.
And if you'd like to catch some
more of these videos after I/O,
head on over to g.co/io/guide.
[LIGHT TECHNO MUSIC]